hello guys my name is Jenna and welcome
back to the Sparky Engine series in
which we take a look at making a game
engine from scratch in C++ and OpenGL so
this episode we're going to be taking a
look at Visual Studio and this should be
a rough overview of how to use Visual
Studio and a few things that might come
in handy along our awesome journey to
creating this thing in less than 40 days
now it's a lot of that's coming up
anyway that aside we're going to be
basically taking a look at video studio
so cool this is not supposed to be some
massive overview a lot of the things
will basically come as we go on you know
with our journey so I'm not gonna
pretend to cover everything here I'm
just going to cover a few basics so that
you can get started and so that you know
basically what's going on so first of
all yeah so this is what this is where
we left off where we left off last time
so we had this dummy little program of
ours and I'm going to kind of use this
to aid us to aid myself and explain
things but this is Visual Studio okay if
you download the theme in the
description you can I think see episode
2 for information on how to actually
install that theme but this is you'll
get the same layout as what I've got
okay and this is generally the layout I
use I also use a program called visual
assist okay and visual assist is a great
little plugin for visual studio I'm not
using it right now because it's not free
so I don't really want to use anything
that isn't free kind of to make this so
I'm not using it I do usually use it
though but no visual assist here okay so
anyway you should get roughly the same
panel okay or offer the same layout so
let's start with exploring everything if
I just close this solution so if you go
file and close leisure names we can kind
of start off with this and what you'll
see is on the view start page this is
what you'll kind of see if you if you
open this up for the first time or not
for the first time but you know when
you're not running it when you open it
so over here we can make new projects we
can open projects we've got our recent
hello world all this stuff you guys will
probably understand but the way I open
my project was I clicked on holo world
okay
that's what we'll be doing when we're
making the engine this is really basic
stuff I probably what I'll probably stop
stopping now but um that's the idea okay
once we're in this view we've got
few different panels here that are
pretty interesting first there's a
solution Explorer not to be confused
with team Explorer which we don't even
need so I might just close that solution
Explorer is essentially your directory
kind of Explorer right it's supposed to
show you every single file that is
included in your project
now the disaster comes here some files
that are actually in your source
directory on your hard drive will not
appear here unless they're actually
included in the project and this is
where a lot of people get lost in
Eclipse or something if you add a file
to the directory you hit a 5 or whatever
to refresh your navigator or package
Explorer or whatever you're using you'll
actually see the file here Visual Studio
doesn't work that way right it has only
the files that are included in your
project if you want to view all files
there's this button up here called show
all files now show all our show all
files won't be there if you've got the
solution or yeah if you've got the
solution selected so you can see
disappears right it's here now but if I
click here it all disappear so a lot of
people might be like I can't see it
that's probably why right if you click
on your project you should be able to
have this show all files button if you
click show all files your view will
probably change a bit and it will show
you every single file so for example if
I want to open my project on where is it
open folder in win File Explorer right
I'll see my hello my hello world
directory and if I add a new file for
example I should say I copy main and I
call this new dot cpp right over here in
my normal thing it will never appear
right it won't be here if I want to
include it in my project I have to click
on show all files and you can see there
it is it's got like a little red thing
next to it if you right-click on that
and hit included project it will
actually be included in your project
it'll be compiled since it's a CPP file
and all that good stuff all right
similarly you can exclude things from
projects ok that's basic file management
is pretty important ok any folders you
create here as well will will be created
on disk and if you want to actually view
the hierarchy because if you see here we
just have source files if I hadn't
you folder or whatever it's not really
going to reflect here whereas over here
if I have folder you can see debug
release all those folders are exactly
the same as what they are on my hard
drive so you probably I honestly I
usually use the show all files mode when
I'm just developing stuff alright and
then I'll have a folder called source
for example for all of my source files
and that's how I'll have this set up so
that's really important okay show all
files is probably the most important
button on here
obviously there's refresh as well if you
want to refresh everything and see any
new files that you've added on disk
anyway that's the basic idea right so we
can delete this new thing and it should
be deleted from disk cylinder from disk
as well alright cool
anyway that's the basic idea let's move
on here so class view this is kind of
like the outline that that uh Eclipse
has visual assists like class view thing
is fly a bit better but you can see that
for example under in the hello world
project we've got entity we've got
player and the point is it kind of shows
us it doesn't really show us the files
classes well alright I don't even have
visual assist so I can't open file
anyway it just shows us generally the
stuff that we've got like player and
it's just a general class kind of
Explorer it's kind of used for sometimes
if you want to take a look so we can see
what entity what player is and we can
see that entity is based type fly anyway
you can search here in one more class
who's kind of important alright let's
move on
arrow lists are very important right if
I make an error such as quickly just
there's a touch bigger ok I forget a
semicolon or something we'll get an
arrow here now what's kind of important
is that if I do something that isn't
really an error right so I actually
demonstrated this when I worked not
build so adding new files by the way you
can right click on project hit add new
item it doesn't have to be on a project
it can be on any folder right and use
out a new item
alright cool if I have a header file
that is called do I already have a
you've got um what's call this example
right and I do something stupid like
have a
a bracket here and then over here I as I
demonstrated this example last time and
I include a header I'll include thing
Intel you can see that this basically
you get an arrow right this isn't
actually an arrow if I run this role
wrong file if I run this you can see we
don't actually get an error right but we
have an error okay that's intellisense
intellisense is usually not to be
trusted
okay it can it is useful sometimes for
diagnosing things like this but you can
see these errors are basically just
visual studios kind of opinion on what's
wrong okay
it's not actually a build failing so if
you want to see only errors that are
actually real errors right click here
and just don't show intellisense errors
and you can see that now we don't have
any errors if we build we don't get any
errors and of course if we had an actual
error like that and we tried to build
this it would actually give us a real
error
okay so intellisense you'll usually see
that disabled especially when this
project gets a bit bigger and we start
doing fancy things intel says just isn't
going to be able to keep up all right so
that's one thing I wanted to mention
here okay breakpoints we're about it we
will talk about debugging in one on in
this video so I'll get onto that
eventually okay find symbol results um
this is useful because well it I mean if
it'll appear automatically but if I do
something like shift f12 for example on
something what it will do is it will
search for definitions okay so in this
case you can see it's searched a lot
more than just this file alright and a
few shortcuts I will get onto in the in
the future but yeah essentially if I
want to see where player is you this is
kind of like the show all references in
Eclipse if you right-click and go like
work special references it will just
show what it's used right so if I go
right click it all you can see shift f12
is find all references okay so we'll
search for everywhere player is used so
if I were
player and I'm like aha who's using this
constructor theoretically it won't just
look for the constructor unfortunately
but it will find you know the usages of
this for example in Maine you can see
here I can't we're making an object here
okay
so that's important then this is what
the find symbol results will kind of
contain all right find results is a bit
different so if I was actually searching
for a string of text if I just hit ctrl
shift F you'll see this find a replace
dialog all right you don't have to
replace that's different but when you're
searching for things you can actually
search in them in various like I guess
search domains right so current document
means just this file all open documents
means all open documents entire salute
and that current project will mean just
the whole I world project if you've got
multiple projects in your solution you
can actually search the entire solution
as well which is really cool so again if
I wanted to see where player was defined
I could search for player hit find all
and you can see there will be here if
you just want to see where they actually
I if you just click on it once it will
show you where it is all right which is
pretty cool so you can see in this case
it's in the include player all right
cool before we go any further I'm just
going to turn on line numbers here
because it's a bit annoying not seeing
line numbers and visually I think visual
studio now by default doesn't have line
numbers so if you go into tools options
and then under text editor in all
languages alright just on general which
is just that you'll see line numbers
just hit OK on that and then you'll be
able to see what line of code you're on
which is very useful when you're looking
at error messages especially alright
cool so yeah you can see that if I go
through this list all yeah anyway you
guys can get the drift that's just a
quick interface kind of tutorial thing
all right
the output is pretty self-explanatory
most errors in the output but pretty
much all errors in the output will
appear here seven with warnings so you
don't really need to read this too much
there are ways of course to actually log
into the output when it's actually
running okay well when you want your
application is running and when you're
debugging it so that's very useful as
well in case you don't have a console
will probably have an actual console
there so
it probably isn't too important but um
that's the Apple window okay cool so a
few keyboard shortcuts I don't know I'd
probably don't know all of them in fact
it'll assist does a lot of stuff that I
probably don't know about but the basic
ones I use are probably stuff like
ctrl-c and ctrl-v Lowell
a lot of people actually don't know how
to use a keyboard when they're
programming which is interesting because
I I teach people privately a lot um and
by the way in case you guys are
interested in that it'll be a link in
description to of course private
tutoring but um I teach a lot of people
and a lot of them are always amazed at
how fast I type and how I you know
navigate let's just say navigate the
Seas of code well really it's just all
about knowing how to use your keyboard
so for example when you're navigating
text instead of just using the arrow
keys it's pretty much everyone knows how
to do you can actually combine these
with shortcuts and with buttons other
buttons on your keyboard so for example
if I hold down control and it's amazing
how many people don't know this as well
I know tons of you gonna absolutely know
this so just sit tight maybe skip
fast-forward a bit this is for those who
don't okay if you hold down control
while using the arrow keys alright
specifically the left and right arrow
keys you'll actually skip entire words
this is something that again a lot of
people don't know for some reason if I
hold down control you use the up and
down arrow keys it'll simply scroll but
left and right it'll actually go through
words so if I'm trying to replace int
with a long for example you wouldn't see
me go right I'll do something like ctrl
+ shift then the right arrow key to
select the word then long okay quick
tutorial for you guys right so I can
select a lot of text like that really
quickly alright then there's a few other
buttons on your keyboard that you should
get familiar with such as home and end
they're really the big ones
if I hit home it's going to take me to
the beginning of a line if I hit home
again it'll take me to the actual
beginning of a line
and will take me to the end of a line of
code why is this useful if I'm trying to
select an entire line such as result and
copy it I can hit up once for example
home twice then shift and then down all
right that will select the line ctrl C
will copy it and I can paste it as many
times as I won and you can see the
actual line is selected so it'll it
includes the am blind character okay so
that's really important
okay so again get acquainted with that
stuff if you want to be a bit faster and
you really share anyway because it will
save you time cool I need the other
stuff is pretty much the same for most
text editors if I am if I hold down alt
while just if I hold down alt and then
I'm on this particular line of code and
I use the up and down arrow keys we'll
just move down line up and down okay
it's annoying
to undo that stuff though alright so you
might not want to go too crazy with that
especially if you've got valuable stuff
in your undo stack but that's the idea
okay old and whatnot is very useful if
you're just remove code and you can do
it with bug with um with a selection of
code as well not just one one cool um
yeah
I think that's pretty much it um I you
know obviously you can if I want to
select the line this way or whatever
shift an end for example will select
that just kind of get used to that stuff
insert as well will override character
so if I want to choose 0 to the one I
can to a one I can just do that all out
of that anyway that's the insert thing a
lot of people probably know that um just
looking at my keyboard anything else
particularly useful probably not ok so
that's pretty much it if I do something
in this video that's weird I'll probably
just cover that but that's basic text
editing skills which a lot of people
don't know and should so there you enjoy
ok so ah what else do we have on the
agenda here oK we've got a few um I was
going to show you guys how to do a few
things we'll say ok cool so I think what
we'll do now okay one thing that's kind
of annoying as well is that if you're
looking at a file
such as main doors EVP I'm like I want
to see this on my hard drive if you
right-click on this unfortunately for
some weird reason there is no like find
on desk or open an explorer button right
it's just not here if you double click
on it to open it and it appears as a tap
here you can actually well eh you can
hover your mouse over and it will tell
you where it is but if you right-click
on the actual tab you can actually open
the containing folder here ok
odd that it's not in here but it's it's
available here so it's not too bad ok
just get used to that one thing that's
also really useful in the interface is
this kind of scope thing so this tells
me that I'm in the hello world project
this tells me what scope I'm in so I'm
in the global scope right and this tells
me what like in a scope I'm in so for
example this add function right so if I
was in let's just say player right you
can see that if I'm in the players kind
of namespace scope thing you'll tell me
that I'm in player and then that's the
destructor for player so this is kind of
useful as well if you're looking for
something like eclipses outline and you
don't want to use the class view if you
just click down on this it'll show all
the methods that are in here ok so you
can see we've got get X that has
structure and the constructor and then
it works with header files the same way
right cool so entity probably has a few
more things not really we're looking at
pretty small groups of code but there
you go so that so if you drop down here
you can see a quick overview of all of
the functions that are actually in here
all right awesome
so moving on um yeah if I want to go to
a definition if you literally
right-click on something you'll see a
bunch of shortcuts here so f12 for
example if I'm going to see where player
defined I hit f12 and look it takes me
right to the header file so that's
another release or shortcut that you
could have probably figured out if you
looked at this
alright cool um so moving on let's talk
about different projects and how we can
get them to kind of interact so for
example this print method that we have
in header write print entity for example
that's probably a bad example let's just
say we have
name space chana and then inside the
channel namespace we have a void print
and this will just take in let's just
say just a string a normal C string roll
a normal C string are taxed and all it
will do is it will print it out so and
I'll pull a print line for example since
it has a newline character okay that's
all I've got it's a very simple function
right right now if I want to call it
again I include header and then if I
call it I simply type in Cherno print
line and then we can say something like
hello whoops all right if I run this we
get the hello and everything is nice but
let's just say this whole kind of setup
I don't actually want it here I want it
to be in a different project this will
become a bit more apparent when we write
a lot of code and we don't want to keep
compiling it or we want to kind of
modularize our entire projects right so
what we want to do is we want to yeah
might we basically want to have separate
components for each component of our
game image and we might have one for
graphics well and have one for audio we
might have one for like special tax
reloading or something we don't want to
have everything in one project okay so
what we can do is we can actually kind
of outsource this to another project
compile it compile it into a library and
then simply link it and use it as a
library okay very cool so what we can do
is we can right click on solution if you
want to add a project and you go file
new project it will probably created a
new solution okay unless you actually
pick add to solution that's just
complicated so we can just right click
on the solution here in the solution
Explorer if you want to get any windows
back by the way under view you'll see
everything cool right click hit add and
then new project you'll add it to the
solution so if I call this it'll be an
empty project I'll call this printer
because it's going to print things under
source files I'll just quickly add
printer dot CPP and
printer dot H so the reason I'm doing
this by the way is just to show you a
basic workflow between projects and also
how to set up projects to use external
references which is very important so
printer we've got printed page so again
I'll have my pragma once header god I'll
have my include printed or H and then
what I'll do is I'll just I'll have my
I'll literally go into let's see I'll
literally go into where header right and
I'll just cut this code here and then
under printer I'll have this right and
then so we've just got this right I will
probably have to include standard i/o no
iostream sorry I'm thinking seal and for
some reason so we've included that and
then I obviously want to have this
function so it's not inside a class by
the way here it's just inside a
namespace it's just a normal function if
I I want to declare it here as a
prototype so I've got println and I know
that it takes in a string so this is the
definition of course make sure it is
inside the namespace I'll talk a bit
about conventions as well you might
notice that I put some things on the
line some like some brackets eyes some
braces I put on the newline and whatever
we'll talk a bit about convention as
well in a minute but we've got this
print line here it's actually
implemented here and it's inside these
names faces everything is nice so let's
go ahead and and we know that it works
were tested in another thing this
project let's compile it into a library
so how can we do that
so under printer if we hit properties
you'll see this printer property pages
some reason were actually already in
release mode let's go back to Devo for a
minute if we go to the properties let's
drop in on the just general literally
and you'll see the configuration type on
the project defaults right if we change
this to we can change this to a number
of things such as static library dynamic
library and a few different things so
right now it compiles into an executable
and that's fine for most things right if
we actually wanted to have a main method
or a main function and we wanted to
actually run it on its own but if we
want to reference it in other things
yeah what we want to do is we want to
actually compile it into both a static
library and a dynamic library now static
library is usually used for basically
debugging and for actually writing code
with right so this is kind of like an
API thing whereas dynamic library is
pretty much a binary that you provide
which gets dynamically linked into an
exe file for example when it actually
runs so a few differences but in actual
real worlds kind of scenario the static
libraries I'm going to use while you're
developing and then when you want to
actually run the application once it's
built you want to include a DLL file so
we basically need both of these so if I
just go to a static library here let's
go to open folder in Windows Explorer
one thing you'll see right now is I've
never actually built it so on the
printer there's no debug there's no
anything there are any folders if I
right click on this and hit build we'll
wait for it to succeed we get a nice
entry point must be defined which is
just beautiful so let's go back into
printer here make sure that it's set as
a startup project I'll probably talk
about that in a minute and then we can
build it again so we're looking linking
arrows which is just so much fun low so
after wasting like a good minute or so I
realized what the problem was the
problem is we're currently in it in
debug mode and if I go to properties the
properties we modified when we change
this to whatever was actually the
release configuration so make sure
you're modifying the right configuration
so under the active configuration we
want to change that to be a static
library for example ok hit OK
right click here build and it should
succeed ok so again that's very silly
and that's how I'm going to kind of glad
that happened because I got to tell you
this so make sure the configuration that
you're actually modifying settings for
actually matches your current
configuration otherwise it just won't
work or your settings basically won't
affect anything so make sure so we've
compiled a static library now
we've hit build you'll see now on the on
the printer
you have a debug folder okay in this
debug folder you'll see a bunch of stuff
okay you won't actually see what you're
looking for which is the dot Lib file
for some reason it just did not decide
to put it here what it does it actually
puts it into your solution so under
debug yeah in the holo world project so
under the actual solution where we have
both our hello Weldon printer things we
have debug alright and here you'll see
the printer dot Lib file all right this
is our static library and under
properties by the way you can change all
this stuff you see these output
directory this intermediate directory
yeah you can change all these
directories if you like ok that's just
where it does it but if all those
changes to a dynamic library hit OK
right click hit build and then you'll
see that we have a printer DLL and
printed Lib fantastic so now we can use
this printer in our other code let's
figure out how we can do that for the
purposes of this I'm just going to
remove this project completely ok if I
hit okay it'll be removed the reason I
did that was just because you can see it
didn't actually delete the files I just
removed it for me I just want to
basically complicate this list and show
you that I'm not just simply referencing
and I'm actually not the code isn't
being compiled or anything anymore at
all it's just it's just it's already
been compiled into two files and that's
that also I did compile it as a debug
build again this is just for testing
purposes not for releasing or whatever
so we've got printer DLL and we've got
printed out live these are our products
how do we use them in hello world now so
the thing is we'll actually need one
more thing
we basically need three things to be
fully set up with this project we want
we've got these
sorry we've got the lib in dll we also
need the header file which is printed I
um and you can see it's just 94 bytes of
glory so if we copy this and I'm just
going to put this into here for now make
a new folder called printer API right
and then I'll put all these a lot of
lovely files into this folder so you can
actually see everything we basically
need so under printer API excuse me
while I just cut this for a minute and
put it out into the real world
under printer diapir we've got three
files all right I'm gonna I'm gonna
basically toss this into three
directories for you we've got our
includes which is printed by age yeah
we've got our in fact I'm just going to
put this into a Cherno folder just to
because it is in Cherno namespace so
we'll just we'll be nice we've got our
binaries which is printer DLL and then
we've got our Lib which as you can
imagine is printed on Lib okay so this
is typically three directories at three
directories you'll see when you actually
download someone else's library what
we're going to do now is include these
and use them in our holo world project
so as you can see we don't have the
print thing anymore and Hatter
everything's gone let's go back to main
figure out how this actually works
so I'll set main back as data project of
course it has been that has been done
because we deleted the other project but
make sure you set the right project as
this data project very important you can
see this currently is an error okay so
what we want to do first of all is
include this our head file right because
that has the definitions this header
file has the definitions of how we can
actually call this function doesn't have
the implementation or anything but it
tells us how we can actually use this
function so we want to include it now we
could just copy it into one of these
directories and include it I'm not going
to do that instead I want to teach you
guys how to add a new include directory
so under properties for our project
we've got basically two options under V
C++ directories we've got our include
directories we could add here in
c / c++ there's also additional under
general there's also additional include
directory so you can add it here you can
add it wherever you want okay I'm just
going to add it here for no particular
reason so what I'm going to do is I want
to just copy this path right and then
pop it in here
okay you can also use macros I think
they're called here yeah so you can
actually use if you don't want to if you
want to have a relative path you can
also use a macro for example to get the
current solution directory so that if
someone else downloads this project file
and you know they'll probably won't have
a user called Sparky and whatever so you
might not want an absolute path but this
is just how to set it up on your
computer so use macros if you like so
we've included this as an additional
include directory okay what that means
now is we can use these angular brackets
so in last in last episode's video I
actually forgot to mention the
difference between these if you're using
quotes it means your relative to the
current file so it means I'm relative to
main dot CPP so if I open this
containing folder I can see that I've
got for example player door age I can
include that because I'm in the correct
directory yeah I can also for example in
this case if I really wanted to go to
printer API you'll see that the current
directory that I'm in is hello world so
I need to go back a directory then into
printer API and include so I can
actually do that can go back a directory
like that go back into printer API
include oops include Cherno and then
printer page that's perfectly valid
alright
angular brackets are four paths or
basically paths that originate in a
directory that we've actually told the
compiler to add as an include directory
so in this case we did specify this
directory right so that will be that is
an additional include directory that is
an include directory so when we use
angular brackets it will actually search
that so now we can just use that hit up
Cherno and then slash printed on edge
you can use backslash as a force letter
some windows doesn't matter okay cool so
there we go so now we've included and
you can see where it is again if I just
included that other directory I didn't
make that sure no folder we could just
do that
cool if you really want you can get rid
of the extension completely right and
just literally on this get rid of the
extension and then you'll have it you
can have it kind of like a lot of the
C++ libraries are so it's up to you but
I like having the extension there just
to remind me it's a header file but um
there we go all right so there is that
printable age so now you can see the
arrow goes away so can we run this can
we build it can we just be awesome now
no we get this scary error message that
a lot of people are very frightened by
okay unresolved external symbol I
remember back in the day I used to be
scared of this one because there's a lot
of out signs here and look that's just
not a good time so what this means is
that literally unresolved external
symbol okay
so it found this print line it's fine
it's in the header file that we included
but a lot I love how I actually went to
pray why do we go to that that's very
smart that one where is this ah it's
cool it still thinks it's part of it
that's annoying anyway we'll get all
that so pretend it's not here okay um
it's amazing that it did that it has the
definite it has the definition of the
function so it knows how to call it
that's why we don't get an error here
and we don't actually get a compile
error we get a linking error okay hence
the LNK prefix to the error code the
problem is it's found the function
definition it knows how to use the
function but then when the linker
actually tries to look for the function
itself to make this Cherno print line
actually do something it can't
physically find it so it has a
definition but it cannot find the
implementation that is all this error
means and in this you can see it says
we've got a deckle here and then shadow
print line it actually tells you what
function it can't find which is nice and
it tells you that's referenced in this
main function alright fantastic so all
we need to do is tell it where this is
so how can we do that well glad you
asked because back in here on the vase
episode directories you'll see a library
directories we want to point it to that
dot Lib file or that the directory that
has
Lib file so again if I go to my printer
API
I go to Lib and then I find this I can
copy this path paste it in here hit OK
again you can use macros whatever to get
relative paths to the current solution
directory directory or whatever we've
got this and then we can hit OK and it's
all good isn't it no it's not we've
given it the actual directory so it's
like an additional include directory but
when we included something we had to
actually like when we added an include
directory we actually had to use the
include didn't we same with libraries so
how do we do that well on the properties
under linker because remember this isn't
a compiling thing this is a linking
thing now on the input there's
additional dependencies over here just
click on the drop down menu and edit
your annemun have to do that you can
just type here by the way so I can just
type stuff here but I'm just doing this
so that you guys can see this a bit more
clearly we want to type in print ad lib
okay obviously you will never find this
unless you actually give it this
directory which is what we did in the
previous step so make sure you do that
all right let's get ok okay cool there
we go print result lib is now here hit
OK so if we run this now if we build it
my goodness it succeeded are we ready to
rock and roll let's just hit it to run
it and we are ok fantastic so in this
case it didn't actually need a DLL so
luckily right but usually if we go into
for example I've got a feeling that's
actually because of a few different
things but if we go into our global
application into sorry just into debug
and we launch a low world ok great
it works fantastic so it's probably
actually compiled the DLL into this exit
because the diello is freaking tiny but
usually you would need this DLL here in
our fantastic hello world application to
actually run it in fact in a release
mode actually do something like that ok
we'll talk about that in a minute ok
cool so that's essentially how you use a
library it's pretty simple it's not too
difficult let
move on to a few different build
configurations and whatnot and then I'll
go through debugging and I think we'll
be done so if I under properties here if
I change the the build configuration to
release right and I build it will
probably get errors right and you'll be
like what you mean I specify this
include directory remember each
configuration has his own set of
properties so make sure you are nice
this time and what you might want to do
is just go to debug and copy and paste
pretty much all the stuff like the
include stuff so I'll just Lowell copy
paste okay you might want to do all that
stuff stuff involved and stuff you've
changed okay well have been modified
make sure you hit yes when you go
between them so that's kind of nice I
also like the fact that if you if you
keep clicking on things like that this
actually becomes wider and wider is
pretty quite comical really but we also
want the library directories to be
included so I'll copy and paste that and
then finally we want yes we want the
additional include directories under
general to also be in the release
configuration all right cool
and now if we run this it should totally
work okay cool
now we get errors okay this is because
of the difference in configuration so
for example printers will Lib
iteratively by value to doesn't match
value to the reasons this basically
happened is because we didn't really
compile our printer in release mode but
don't worry okay again this was this is
just a little test application one thing
I want to note is that when you're doing
release you might want to actually
change the optimization okay so for
example stuff like maximize speed will
be on instead of like basically disabled
which is what debug will probably have
all right disabled you also might want
to you know you probably want to change
in line yeah there's a bunch of things
you probably want to setup for example
you want to obviously favor fast code
and all these optimizations which
actually do make a massive difference
okay you can probably get your
application running ten times or more
faster if you set these out probably
again there's a few other things like on
the code generation you might want to
change the floating model to be fast and
the instruction set to be for example
sse and there's just there's a bunch of
different things you can set up here
that is really important we'll be
setting up a bunch of them throughout
the ink engine series to make our game
engine run faster and release builds but
the general downside is is it becomes
harder to debug all right which is why
we don't really want to do this on a
debug build that's why we have two
different builds so there's released
which in our case will probably be the
one that will get distributed but debug
is the one that we'll work on okay
because it'll be easier to debug things
let me show you the difference between
the two built quickly if I go back to if
we just hit OK and that so it applies
this one thing you will do by the way is
since run remember since debug builds
we'll have sorry since each different
build configuration actually has its own
separate like set of properties it also
has two separate folders okay so you'll
see hello world has debug okay and then
hello world has what we had the DLL in
there
I wonder if Phil's yeah it still still
work without it well okay whatever I'm
actually quite surprised anyway
we you can see we've got release here
okay didn't really succeed in building
because of all these debug level
measurement Mitch mismatches
I'll talk but we have this release
directory that I generated okay so it'll
generate multiple directories so if we
go up here quickly and let's just remove
this printer thing because that was more
of a testing if I build this now it
should build successfully and we should
see that our hello world release
directory has this exe file which is
great let's quickly do something to just
see the actual difference between builds
under debug if I let's just say I have
an integer called
two and three and then I want to add
them together using the add function and
when we go a B and then I'll log this
see ya if I'm in a debug build all right
let's build this for a minute make sure
it stays cool I'm going to put a
breakpoint at log okay and then I'm
going to run this and we'll go through
breakpoints in a minute and you'll see
that when I run this it'll actually
physically stop the application at that
break point and we can examine our
current program okay specifically things
like memory and what's in there so a you
can see what we'll go over this
interface in a minute so we're about to
you know start on the debugging side of
this which is the last section in this
video but you'll see that we we've put
an application call nothing really looks
that different in fact let's do it at C
so I'll stop this and I'll rerun it okay
we've good C right let's right-click and
just hit go to disassembly so what
you'll see here is basically the
assembly equivalent of what our code has
been compiled into and we can see it
running here what you can see is that
this is again this mode is probably not
too useful to the average user because a
lot of stuff you can debug here but this
is actually quite useful when you just
essentially don't know what the compiler
is doing okay lets you verify that your
compiler is actually compiling them
correctly and it's not over optimizing
stuff to the point where it breaks or
there's just there's a lot of there's a
lot of uses for this but basically it
just lets you figure out what actual
instructions are being sent to the CPU
so in this case you can see we've got a
bunch of so this is the line of code is
being executed these are all the
instructions that will be executed for
that line of code okay so it's good if
you've under viewing options and stuff
like show source code which is very
useful okay but and then there's also
you know show symbol names which is kind
of useful otherwise you don't know what
it's actually doing so for example um
over here you can see it's actually
calling the add function fantastic and
is evaluating this stuff so it's for
example in this case it's actually
setting a specific memory address to the
value two okay and if you've done any
assembly as a lot of this will look
familiar but the point is we can see
that it's actually you can see there's
actually there's an actual function call
in here now this is a very basic thing
and we did
I need a function call for this so if we
can pilot in release mode okay and we
hit f5 first of all you can see the
breakpoint didn't even stop at sea right
there is no see yeah which is straight
away it's a bit interesting if we go to
the disassembly now you'll see it looks
very different
first of all these lines of code are
basically one thing okay because what is
done is this is if apart from just
simply in lining all these functions
which or this add function because if
there's no call to the add function the
only call we have is to some other
function which is probably the actual
printing function to print this to our
console but it's essentially combine
these things evaluate the compilers
actually evaluated it itself and has
basically set up C and already logged it
right and you can see it's pushing five
and five is what two plus three is okay
so you can see that the compiler is in
this release build has actually gone so
far as to simplify this statement and
not computer runtime okay it actually
figures it out while it's compiling
which is beautiful and then it pushes
this five and it calls the function and
basically prints up and the UM the
number five into our console okay so
that is a good example to demonstrate
the difference between configurations
and what release mode will actually do
it will optimize your code it's very
useful and as is this disassembly window
which actually showed us what it did so
it again we simplify this into five
whereas before of course in debug mode
we had we had this did everything
separately and it called the actual add
function you can see call add okay and
release mode did not so keep that in
mind I can't actually zoom in in this by
the way for some reason but keep that in
mind
very useful moving on so let's talk let
go back to debug mode that's also an
example of such a wide a bug is probably
a bit more useful you can see that stuff
like in ABC would all take up memory
they take up four bytes each of memory
to store these numbers and really smell
it's like no we don't need to waste that
memory will just evaluate this and
literally just do that
so and then that removes this all right
cool anyway let's talk a bit about but
that's why debug mode is important for
debugging right because we don't want
these variables to be removed if we're
trying to diagnose what's going on with
our program so very important stuff okay
cool so let's let's take a quick look at
the bugging because I basically want to
be done I basically want to have this
thing done and within an hour so so
we'll do that but um debugging so
breakpoints we're going to basically
focus this whole debugging thing about
breakpoints you'll see this massive like
gray kind of Thomas green ish kind of
space here between the line numbers and
like this solution Explorer right
there's this space right and I guess
this either word depends how zoomed in
you are but it's this thing
right if you click once anywhere right
it will pray it place this big red
button thing now to someone who has no
idea what it is this will destroy your
life because when every time you're on
your program it'll stop it'll crash and
you'll be like bro what up so don't
freak out it's called a breakpoint and
it's incredibly useful basically when
you place it at a particular line of
code and you run your application your
application will stop when it reaches
that line of code okay so for example if
I place one in a and hit run you can see
our program never even stops which means
a never runs so that's a kind of a
useful feature we can basically
instantly see does a get called anywhere
in our code Lowell no it doesn't so
we've got this good so we can place it
anywhere and it will stop okay
f9 if you're on any line f9 will place
or remove a breakpoint pretty useful so
when we do this it will it will pause
our application and it will show us a
bunch of things first of all it'll show
us a few values which are important to
us
in the bottom here you'll see autos
locals and watch these windows aren't
present in the when you're not debugging
right when you aren't debugging you get
this different kind of view okay so
under under autos it'll orders I think
it I'm not sure exactly what it's when I
was supposed to do I think it just kind
of grabs a few variables that you
it thinks will be important to you to
look at right locals will just look at
every local variable you've got so we've
got three here and then watch allows you
to basically tell it what variables to
look at so if I click here and type in a
it'll tell me the value eight of a right
I can also click and drag variables in
and stuff and it will tell me it's
values so that's kind of useful as well
and you can have you can see it says
watch one that's because you can have
like for watch windows they're not under
view by the way these windows they're on
the debug and windows okay so you can
see this watch we can have after four
watches okay there are other important
things like um little modules modules
the modules are kind of important when
you've got a lot of projects and you not
sure like for example you might not have
debug symbols being loaded from some
things anyway um so under debug we've
got Windows you know we've got threads
and whatnot and a lot of these are
pretty useful but these are probably the
most important ones so we'll focus on
them cool so we've we've broken light
right we broke on this line of code on
line 41 we've got a yellow arrow there
and if you if we hover our mouse over it
it says this is the next statement that
will be executed right this hasn't
actually been executed yet technically
the last thing that's been executed is
like this little curly bracket right eh
this int a equals two that has not
actually been executed that line of code
right so if we want to step forward in
time one line so we want to advance our
program one line we can actually do some
pretty cool stuff like that so up the
top here you'll see a few different
things along with shortcuts right so
there's the three ones were kind of
interested in and there's also continue
which is important which is f8 okay
doesn't actually say it but it is
impacted sorry it's f5 its f8 in Eclipse
I think I don't know why I thought of
that but f5 okay so there's step in to
step over and step out they're all
really useful so step over we'll simply
step to the next line of code so if I
hit f10 or click on step over you can
see that the yellow arrow advances right
and we've actually moved so we've
executed this and our autos tells us the
eighth actually says that it in like a
red kind of font it says that a is
changed into two okay the reason it's
red is because it's changed since last
time
let me quickly see if I can actually
increase the tools option increase the
font of this because that is kind of
annoying
we'll just do it in will do and watch so
let's quickly just not color let's
quickly spice this up to like eighteen
so I shall relaunch watch or the whole
application hopefully not the whole
application are you serious what does it
say
man hang on let's change it to fourteen
watch windows I did restart that well
debug window whoops okay
debug windows watch fantastic did I
change this right option I did great oh
my goodness
alright let's restart Visual Studio I
guess all right sorry about that guys
hopefully uh hopefully this actually
works okay good um so yeah so you can
see a is currently that that's just
because it's undefined right it hasn't
actually put anything into that memory
that's just the memory address of a and
a hasn't been allocated by us if we had
f10 you can see thread because it's
changed into that new value of to be
still hasn't so if I hear that again a
is now white because it hasn't changed
since last time and be free so I'm
simply just stepping over right that's
alone doing this is fantastic because it
shows you the control flow of your of
your application if you're still kind of
learning programming and you're not sure
how
for example control flow works so if
Damon's for loops you know breaks and
you know all everything
continues whatever you're not really
100% sure about how you program actually
execute code you can step through it
line by line okay very very useful stuff
for education and for this stuff now
here I have a function right if I hit
step over it will simply value 8c right
so I'll just type in C now watch so we
can look at it it's 5o and you that's it
it'll just step over it right what if I
want to actually see what the ab
function does well I can okay if I hit
f5 and then I go down here instead of
step over I'm going to want to click
step into what it will do is it'll
actually step into that function okay
and then if I hit f10 if I if I if this
was a long function and I decided you
know what I'm done with this function I
can step out of it and it'll step out of
the function and go back to here okay
then you can see C gets set to five all
right cool
one more useful thing is if you're in a
massive full loop or whatever and you're
like man is going to take me forever to
get to here you can place another
breakpoint at where you want to be hit
f5 and you can see it'll continue on
till so f5 is continue it'll continue
until it reaches that line of code which
is kind of useful as well alright cool
so that being said that's essentially
how we can kind of breakpoint things and
run through this so it's very important
stuff because we see how our program
actually works okay cool
and then these are the three views that
we want to look at so yeah the other
cool thing that we can do is have
conditional breakpoints so if I put
something here okay and I say you know
what I want to break here so if I right
click on it under condition okay
I can actually say C greater than 5 and
when it's true okay so if I run this and
sees 5 it is fine right if I change this
to 6 that or whatever I change it to
let's just say if I see will be 8 in
this case and I run it you can see that
look at that it breaks so that's also
very useful if you're trying out if
you're in a massive loop and you're
trying to only look at certain I don't
know certain iterations of that loop or
you know
for example if I had a massive four loop
here so four in I equal zero is less
than 500 I plus plus right and then I'm
like and then it logged it or whatever
oops and then I was like you know what I
want a breakpoint here
let's stop this
I want a breakpoint here but a man like
if I just place I in this watch as well
I just keep hitting f5 or whatever and
it's demand like I want to see it a
duration 400 will take forever I can
right click on this go condition set I
greater than like 450 or whatever hit f5
and then you can see is now 4 4 451 and
it's logged this a lot of times okay
cool so conditional breakpoints are
pretty useful you can also do other
things like you can tell it what to do
when hit so print message is kind of
important and I can tell it to continue
execution so if I do something like this
and then I can say I want you to print
so I equals and then if I use these
curly brackets I can for example say
print I yep so I will actually print the
variable the value of the variable I so
if I hit and you can see it's like some
diamond things I'll just put a normal
one here if I hit a 5 you can see over
here and in my output it actually prints
the value of I okay and this is this
slows down the application tremendously
as you can see it's like running
extremely slow but you might want to do
something like that okay because you
want to see things so that's the idea
again then of course you can set
conditions for that as well so only when
I is greater than 490 I want you to do
that okay so if I run this again you can
see we get a few things and that's it
okay cool so that's some basic debugger
usage
very important stuff again unless it's
step through our code line by line which
is so useful when you're trying to debug
things and you can verify things quite
easily so one more kind of useful
example al one more thing that you can
do is whoops I forgot place a breakpoint
by the way you can place break
is why your application is running so if
it's got a massive lube and you're like
actually I do want to place a breakpoint
you can do that all right so if we run
this again you can also hover your mouse
over values and that'll tell you what
they are so you don't have to look at
them in these three windows you can just
solve your mouse over them and see where
they are under debug windows there's
also memory so under memory so you can
actually view certain addresses certain
addresses of memory if you want the
actual hex of a value so for example a
how do I get the address of that
variable wall um okay new plan
int P equals memory address I'll pay
okay so P is that so let's P let's take
this let's pump it into here hit enter
that's a terrible view let's go here
hopefully that didn't advance no okay so
here we are so you can see what we've
got here yeah man okay zero zero zero
zero zero and then five okay so the five
is the five right it's actually in our
memory and we can look at it here okay
umm pretty cool stuff and it takes up
that many bits because it's that's 32
bit okay cool
right so that's one more useful thing
you can do again that's very seldom
actually useful but I thought I'd show
you anyway the main reason I want to
show you this is because you can hover
your mouse over variables cool one more
thing and then we're done under add for
example I know that this function unlike
you know what I'm mining out I'm ironing
out my application and this shouldn't be
called anymore in fact I'm not sure why
they've been called somewhere I don't
know where it's ruining my application
number written so much credit around
where it's getting cold wrong if you run
this okay and then we of course break on
one a when add gets cold
you'll see this thing here in New York
then called call stack okay in your call
stack this is basically every line of
code rather every function call that has
gotten you to where you are now to this
breakpoint right so you can see that
this is the actual breakpoint and then
if I double click on this line 43
they'll say well this okay so this we
can now see is what called that right so
if I add another function called Lal and
then this was actually in here for
example in Lowell okay
and then I ran this oops stays undefined
let's put log in there as well so
there's that old up arrow shortcut hmm
Lal must return a value loss anymore
and then we see here you can see that we
go to Maine that calls Lowell right by
the way this says this thing isn't
really correct it says this is the next
statement to execute so that means that
this statement is currently being
executed again I don't know why that
didn't just do that but anyway we've got
this right so we can see that this is
what called Lowell Lowell calls add and
then add is where we're at okay so this
call sack is very useful for exactly
that reason
all right cool anyway thanks for
watching guys if you have any questions
about Visual Studio please leave a link
in description I've covered very little
but I've covered pretty much everything
you should probably need to actually get
going so again if you've got any
questions just leave them in the
comments below and I'll try and answer
as many of them as possible I think on
the weekend is what I'm actually going
to start this series so I've done all
the introductory videos now I really do
have to get on with the series because
again I want to have something bellend
by 11:00 dare so I'm going to so none of
these were streamed again none of these
were actually streamed all these are
just me recording them
I will be streaming them from now on
though okay so if you want to watch
those streams live which you probably do
make sure you go to twitch on TV for
saffiano and you for either follow me
there or probably more effectively or
like I guess a more effective approach
would be to follow me on Twitter because
twitch doesn't really like unless you're
on twitch all the time you probably
won't know that I mean streaming it'll
just send you like some email or
something but on Twitter you're probably
more likely to be following me on
Twitter and you'll have like a phone
with your Twitter feed there so you
might see that so if you follow me on
Twitter twitter.com 4/2 channel I'll of
course announce when I'm about to stream
and then I'll start streaming and will
actually start this game mission so
there should be some time on the weekend
because I won't have time until then
unfortunately so Saturday or Sunday is
what I want to stream and then of course
I will record that stream and post it on
youtube and that'll be the official
first video overriding the spiking
engine where we'll start with the blank
project and everything and make this
awesome sparking game engine so yeah any
questions leave them below it'll like it
hit the like button if you enjoyed the
video and I'll see you guys next time
goodbye